Jake:对我昨天测
Jake: Yeah, I tested it yesterday
Jake:测了测了一半睡着了
Jake: Tested halfway and fell asleep
Jake:然后第二天早上继续测
Jake: Then continued testing the next morning
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:所以没变
Jake: So nothing changed
Jake:我发现可能是他是他是
Jake: I realized maybe it's because of...
Jake:里边是问题
Jake: There's a problem inside
Jake:就关于逻辑的问题
Jake: It's about the logic
Jake:是说是按照逻辑做事还是按照逻辑
Jake: Whether to do things logically or...
Jake:还是按照什么感情做事
Jake: Or follow emotions
Jake:还是以emotion做事
Jake: Still doing things with emotion.
Jake:然后你呢
Jake: And you?
Jake:我可能不按逻辑做事
Jake: I might not do things logically.
Jake:哈哈不按逻辑对
Jake: Haha, not logically, right.
Jake:虽然可能盘一盘逻辑
Jake: Even though I might think it through logically,
Jake:但是不按逻辑做事
Jake: I don't do things logically.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 对制定计划太累了
Lucia: Yes, making plans is too tiring.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 所以我选择随心所欲是的
Lucia: So I choose to go with the flow, yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:眼镜ready呢
Jake: Are the glasses ready?
Jake:就可以戴了
Jake: Then you can wear them.
Jake:薇薇是在里边还是在外边薇薇
Jake: Tasha, are you inside or outside, Tasha?
Jake:你记着戴眼镜
Jake: Remember to wear glasses.
Jake:啊在哪里
Jake: Ah, where?
Jake:呵呵呵报警
Jake: Haha, call the police.
Jake:哎我那天是不是路过一个派出所
Jake: Hey, did I pass a police station that day?
Jake:对昨天是有一个派出所
Jake: Yes, there was a police station yesterday.
Lucia: 他不会吧
Lucia: No way.
Lucia: 他不应该对我把头点吗
Lucia: Shouldn't he nod his head at me?
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh.
Shure:  (歌词)we are the champion my friend
Shure: (Lyrics) We are the champions, my friend.
Jake:静坐
Jake: Sit quietly.
Jake:他们在醋
Jake: They're jealous.
Jake:戴眼镜了吗
Jake: Are you wearing glasses?
Jake:3点了3点了
Jake: It's 3 o'clock, it's 3 o'clock.
Tasha: 我们来玩个游戏吧
Tasha: Let's play a game.
Jake:玩什么呀
Jake: What to play?
Tasha: 你这样子
Tasha: Like this.
Jake:这样嗯
Jake: Like this, hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Tasha: 这个角也抵住这里
Tasha: Put this corner here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你玩过吗
Jake: Have you played it before?
Jake:我可能玩过
Jake: I might have played it before.
Alice: 切一块嘿嘿
Alice: Cut a piece, hehe.
Alice: 然后石头剪刀布
Alice: Then rock-paper-scissors.
Alice: 然后你哎
Alice: And then you, hey...
Alice: 不对是你往后一搁啊
Alice: No, you need to move back a step.
Jake:我要往后一格
Jake: I need to move back a step.
Alice: 呃呃呃这不是烤那蛋糕的那个
Alice: Uh, isn't this the thing for baking that cake?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice: 我我呵呵
Alice: I, I, hehe.
Jake:好惨
Jake: So tragic.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 什么这是单子
Tasha: What, this is the list.
Jake:你的是的嗯
Jake: Yours, right?
Alice: 你把这个抠下来
Alice: You need to remove this part.
Alice: 然后这个还能当盖盖上不上
Alice: Then you can use this as a lid, can't you?
Jake:好玩
Jake: Interesting.
Jake:已经删过了
Jake: It's already been deleted.
Jake:是吗对
Jake: Really, right?
Jake:牛啊早啊
Jake: Amazing, good morning!
Katrina:  昨天有买新的吗
Katrina: Did you buy new ones yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Did you finish the other bottle?
Katrina:  本来就是
Katrina: Of course.
Katrina:  上一次买两瓶
Katrina: We bought two bottles last time.
Katrina:  一瓶已经喝完了
Katrina: One bottle is already finished.
Shure:  杨老板到尝尝面包吧
Shure: Jake, try some bread.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:先对个齐
Jake: Let’s align first.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread dipped in ketchup.
Jake:我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure:  你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try some bread.
Shure:  那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: That bread is super fragrant.
Tasha: 黄油就奶香奶香的了已经
Tasha: The butter gives it a really creamy taste already.
Shure:  是我碰到的吗
Shure: Did I bump into it?
Katrina:  不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Jake:我没动吧
Jake: I didn't touch it, right?
Jake:他怎么调的
Jake: How did he adjust it?
Tasha: 看摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera.
Jake:摄像头回头看摄像头
Jake: Check the camera later.
Shure:  不是这必须调一下VCR我
Shure: No, we need to adjust the VCR.
Shure:  啊这窜下去了是吧
Shure: Ah, it went down, right?
Katrina:  把杯子放在这上
Katrina: Put the cup here.
Jake:珍贵数据扫一扫
Jake: Scan the valuable data.
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my, how many did you drop?
Shure:  不是他应该会掉到我的鞋里吧
Shure: Didn't he drop them into my shoes?
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Uh, shake them out.
Shure:  嗯我抖一抖
Shure: Yeah, I'll shake them out.
Shure:  你把面包再给我
Shure: Give me the bread again.
Shure:  我再煎一片面包
Shure: I'll fry another slice.
Katrina:  我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 有煎一片还是两片
Tasha: Are you going to fry one slice or two?
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: So much butter.
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just fry one slice.
Jake:一片哎在哪来着
Jake: One slice, where is it?
Jake:在这
Jake: Here it is.
Tasha: 哦哦还有裹蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh, there's also cake batter.
Shure:  好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is it tasty? It's okay, right?
Tasha: 好吃
Tasha: It's delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: It smells amazing.
Shure:  嗯可以的
Shure: Yeah, it's good.
Jake:都是凶器
Jake: They're all weapons.
Shure:  是啊就告诉AI这都是危险物品
Shure: Yeah, just tell the AI these are all dangerous items.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake:不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed.
Jake:屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed in the house.
Shure:  从来没开过火是吗
Shure: You've never cooked before?
Jake:屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed in the house.
Jake:就是就是没开火
Jake: Just, just no cooking.
Jake:确实没开过火
Alice: 抖抖吧
Alice: Shake it out.
Alice: 你不得往下抖吗
Alice: Aren't you going to shake it down?
Alice: 你前面又出不去
Alice: You can't get out from the front.
Alice: 劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I suggest you wear socks.
Shure:  应该问题不大
Shure: It should be fine.
Shure:  没事
Shure: No problem.
Jake:你要不
Jake: How about you...
Jake:学检查一下
Jake: Check it out.
Shure:  行我一会去厕所检查一下嗯
Shure: Okay, I'll check it in the bathroom later.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  盘子端过来一下
Shure: Bring the plate over.
Shure:  把这个拿着
Shure: Hold this.
Lucia: 哎那个刚
Lucia: Hey, that just now
Lucia: 那盘子在哪
Lucia: Where's the plate?
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can we use this frying pan for eggs?
Shure:  煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: You can eat fried eggs too.
Shure:  但煎蛋没有没撒盐
Shure: But the fried eggs don't have salt.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Then let's just use this plate for now.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Lucia: 嗯可以先放过去了是吧
Lucia: Yeah, we can put it over there, right?
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: AI拍了短片
Tasha: AI made a short film.
Jake:哼OK
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Alice: 露西你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucia, can you help me pour it in here?
Jake:有咖啡喝吗
Jake: Is there any coffee?
Shure:  有咖啡都是倒的哦
Shure: There's some coffee, it's all poured.
Katrina:  我也要
Katrina: I want some too.
Shure:  当当当管家送来
Shure: Ta-da! The butler brought it.
Shure:  他大概什么时候送来他可能
Shure: When will he bring it? Maybe...
Jake:他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Did he already bring it?
Jake:你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Can you check over there?
Lucia: 再套个袋子
Lucia: Put another bag over it.
Lucia: 要不咱垃圾袋在哪
Lucia: Or where's our trash bag?
Alice: 在这
Alice: Here.
Shure:  没送来吧这不是
Shure: He didn't bring it, right?
Alice: 嗯不会
Alice: Hmm, no way.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  不是没没有新的快递
Shure: No, no new deliveries.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  所以另一家面包去哪
Shure: So, where did the other bread go?
Lucia: 那我再洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands again.
Jake:干碎了3个杯子
Jake: I broke three cups.
Jake:几个杯子
Jake: How many cups?
Alice: 笔跟纸是不是不在这
Alice: Aren't the pen and paper here?
Jake:饼干
Jake: Cookies.
Jake:什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Alice: 便签跟
Alice: Sticky notes and...
Jake:便签纸
Jake: Sticky notes.
Jake:后面也好你看看
Jake: It might be at the back, take a look.
Alice: 好像没有
Alice: Seems like it's not here.
Shure:  你有看到另一袋面包吗
Shure: Did you see the other bag of bread?
Katrina: 另 一袋面包
Katrina: Another bag of bread.
Shure:  你要偷吃了我们不怪你的
Shure: If you sneak a bite, we won't blame you.
Shure:  你就哈哈
Shure: Just laugh it off.
Shure:  大方的说就好
Shure: Just say it openly.
Katrina:  没有我昨天放冰箱的呀
Katrina: No, I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Katrina:  都没有吗
Katrina: Is it all gone?
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Really?
Jake:有吗有
Jake: Is there? Yes, there is.
Shure:  真没不是
Shure: Really, it's not here.
Shure:  好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So weird, a bag of bread is missing.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  难受
Shure: Feeling upset.
Jake:昨天我没有用面包对吧
Jake: Yesterday, I didn't use any bread, right?
Shure:  对咱昨天没吃
Shure: Right, we didn't eat any yesterday.
Shure:  而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: And we forgot to eat the oysters yesterday.
Shure:  该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to make up for it.
Shure:  现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel completely drained.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 嗯哦是哦
Lucia: Hmm, oh, is that so?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:廉价的快乐没有享受得到
Jake: Didn't get to enjoy the cheap joy.
Jake:还丢了3块钱
Jake: And lost 3 yuan.
Tasha: 清蒸生蚝
Tasha: Steamed oysters.
Tasha: 叫什么来着
Tasha: What's it called?
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic... garlic oysters.
Lucia: 哦蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: Oh, the garlic vermicelli kind.
Jake:那再整点
Jake: Let's make some more.
Jake:再整三刀
Jake: Make three more.
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: There's that steamer.
Jake:呵呵呵那得有得有
Jake: Haha, yeah, we have it.
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's easy to steam.
Jake:生蚝首先得有一个生蚝
Jake: First, you need to have an oyster.
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have some?
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: We didn't put it in the fridge last night.
Jake:对没放冰箱
Jake: Yeah, didn't put it in the fridge.
Jake:化疗了没放冰箱
Jake: Didn't store it in the fridge after the treatment.
Shure:  没放冰箱就所以对
Shure: So, we didn't put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 所以生蚝多少钱
Tasha: So, how much are the oysters?
Shure:  总共19块9吧
Shure: In total, 19.9 yuan.
Shure:  得10只大概
Shure: About 10 pieces, I think.
Shure:  还行吧
Shure: It's okay, I guess.
Jake:其实是损失了多少个
Jake: Actually, how much did we lose?
Jake:100新币
Jake: 100 SGD.
Jake:有10个吗
Jake: Was it 10 pieces?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:好造成了100新币的损失
Jake: Okay, so we lost 100 SGD.
Tasha: 让我来打开订单看一下他到底多少钱
Tasha: Let me check the order to see how much it really was.
Shure:  确实是19块9
Shure: It was indeed 19.9.
Shure:  然后10只
Shure: And 10 pieces.
Shure:  不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 SGD.
Jake:但是损失了100
Jake: But we lost 100.
Katrina:  我想尝一小片给谁
Katrina: I want to taste a small piece, who should I give it to?
Lucia: 一小片是什么
Lucia: What do you mean by a small piece?
Katrina:  就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Katrina:  那我直接撕了
Katrina: So I'll just tear it off.
Lucia: 直接撕吧没事
Lucia: Go ahead, tear it off, it's fine.
Tasha: 啊真的
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 19块9一袋
Tasha: 19.9 a bag?
Jake:二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There's no bread on the second floor either.
Shure:  对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, it's so weird.
Shure:  就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just went missing.
Tasha: 我们结账的时候结一袋还是两袋
Tasha: Did we check out with one bag or two?
Katrina:  两袋两袋
Katrina: Two bags, two bags.
Katrina:  购物车里的人
Katrina: The people with the shopping cart.
Jake:装盒的时候还是两袋是吧
Jake: When we packed it, it was still two bags, right?
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包
Tasha: How did we lose a bag of bread?
Katrina:  我记得
Katrina: I remember.
Jake:车上了会吗
Jake: Could it be in the car?
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Oh, are we missing a bag?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: When I put the egg whites in yesterday,
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: there were still two bags.
Tasha: 可是我记得昨天这个里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was still a bag here yesterday.
Katrina:  对我就有两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yes, I put two bags in the fridge.
Shure:  到底是谁偷吃
Shure: Who's the one sneaking food?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: It's right here.
Katrina:  这不是吗这后面
Katrina: Isn't it here, behind this?
Shure:  楼上吧
Shure: Upstairs, maybe.
Jake:是哪来的
Jake: Where did it come from?
Shure:  就是在冰箱里
Shure: It was in the fridge.
Shure:  刚刚大家没找到
Shure: We just couldn't find it earlier.
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: This is so interesting.
Shure:  藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It's hidden behind the Arctic Ocean.
Shure:  从底下掏出蛋吃是吗
Shure: Are you saying we dig out eggs from below to eat?
Katrina:  对哈哈哈
Katrina: Yes, hahaha.
Shure:  完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending.
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh.
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Awesome.
Jake:嗯哼你也可以拍
Jake: Mm-hmm, you can take a picture too.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:来插管
Jake: Come, intubate.
Alice: 我的线
Alice: My line.
Jake:你先在这
Jake: You stay here first.
Jake:不要着急限速
Jake: Don't rush, slow down.
Alice: 结束了吗
Alice: Is it over?
Jake:要要插管
Jake: Need to intubate.
Jake:是还没是要开始
Jake: It's not over, it's about to start.
Katrina:  他没显示电量
Katrina: It's not showing the battery.
Katrina:  是没电
Katrina: There's no power.
Jake:要摁一下
Jake: You need to press it.
Jake:请插管
Jake: Please intubate.
Lucia: 谢谢稍等
Lucia: Thanks, one moment.
Jake:没关系放在这
Jake: No worries, put it here.
Jake:有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Jake:有
Jake: There are.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Shure:  太不容易了
Shure: It's really not easy.
Shure:  我们又活过了一天
Shure: We survived another day.
Shure:  就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: It feels like we manage to keep ourselves alive each day.
Shure:  非常有成就感
Shure: It's very fulfilling.
Jake:就是那个有那个生命条是吧
Shure:  什么生命条
Shure: What raw noodles?
Jake:就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake:刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's about 20.
Jake:嗯吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: And after eating, how many is it?
Jake:都是赛博人
Jake: They're all cyborgs.
Jake:你吃了一口然后生面条就能加个五
Jake: You take a bite and the raw noodles add five.
Katrina:  差不多
Katrina: Pretty much.
Lucia: 哦噢我自己咬着
Lucia: Oh, I bit myself.
Katrina:  生命之减减
Katrina: The reduction of life.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  看着没没肉不行是吧
Shure: Look, you can't do without meat, right?
Shure:  要咬自己的
Shure: Gotta bite your own
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is too delicious
Shure:  然后裹上
Shure: Then wrap it up
Shure:  徐志瑶也太厉害了
Shure: Xu Zhiyao is really amazing
Shure:  然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: Then it's best to fry it with butter
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 刚把自己咬着了啊好疼啊
Lucia: I just bit myself, it hurts so much
Shure:  就是切下来一片然后放入锅
Shure: Just slice it and put it in the pan
Shure:  然后就可以化掉
Shure: Then it will melt
Shure:  然后再把等它化掉之后
Shure: Then after it melts
Shure:  然后你把那个面包放进去
Shure: Then you put the bread in
Jake:太饿了
Jake: I'm so hungry
Jake:啊怎么办歇着
Jake: Ah, what should we do, take a break
Shure:  动手吧
Shure: Let's get started
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这一直递减
Lucia: My health will keep decreasing
Jake:哈哈哈完了
Jake: Haha, it's over
Lucia: 就是持续性的效应
Lucia: It's a continuous effect
Jake:那得一直补
Jake: You need to keep replenishing
Jake:得插管
Jake: Need a drip
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: Keep drinking that magic potion
Shure:  什么魔法药水哦
Shure: What magic potion?
Jake:他掉血了
Jake: He's losing health
Lucia: 好疼啊哈哈哈
Lucia: It hurts so much, haha
Jake:这叫中毒
Jake: This is called poisoning
Jake:中毒效应
Jake: Poison effect
Tasha: 可见你对这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Tasha: Shows how hard you bit that egg
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 不是都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: I haven't bitten my tongue in a long time
Jake:把外套收拾收拾
Jake: Clean up the jacket
Jake:今天天适合出去玩哦
Jake: Today is a good day to go out and play
Tasha: 嗯今天阳光明媚
Tasha: Yeah, it's sunny today
Alice: 而且感觉温度也很适合
Alice: And it feels like the temperature is just right
Alice: 这谁喝的
Alice: Whose drink is this?
Alice: 我记得记得是你
Alice: I remember it was yours
Jake:怎么办
Jake: What should we do?
Jake:到锅里了
Jake: It's in the pot
Tasha: 你怎么这么浪费
Tasha: Why are you so wasteful?
Jake:我都这么倒了
Jake: I poured it like this
Alice: 好香呀哈哈
Alice: It smells so good, haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:哎呀还有几个破生菜
Jake: Oh no, there are still a few broken lettuce leaves.
Jake:浪费还能吃吗吃
Jake: Such a waste, can we still eat them?
Alice:：我害怕你要抓到我嘴里哼
Alice: I'm afraid you're going to shove it into my mouth, hmph.
Jake:这个怎么说
Jake: How do you say this?
Alice: 这个留着吧好
Alice: Let's keep this, okay?
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Alice: 不会是香槟的盖子哦
Alice: Isn't this a champagne bottle cap?
Tasha: 今天要出去玩吗
Tasha: Are we going out today?
Tasha: 今天去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going today?
Jake:今天不出去玩今
Jake: We're not going out to play today.
Tasha: 可恶
Tasha: Darn it.
Tasha: 那今天干嘛
Tasha: Then what are we doing today?
Jake:今天可以
Jake: Today we can...
Jake:今天不用出去玩
Jake: We don't need to go out to play today.
Jake:但是可以到处走走
Jake: But we can walk around.
Jake:附近吧
Jake: Nearby.
Jake:在室内跳跳舞
Jake: Dance indoors.
Jake:收拾收拾房间
Jake: Tidy up the room.
Jake:晃悠晃悠
Jake: Move around a bit.
Jake:放松一下
Jake: Relax a bit.
Jake:今天星期五
Jake: It's Friday today.
Jake:咱先把这收起来吧
Jake: Let's put this away first.
Shure:  这个没了吧
Shure: Is this all gone?
Jake:不能再碎一个
Jake: Can't break another one.
Jake:又得上厕所
Jake: Need to go to the bathroom again.
Jake:又得去厕所看看
Jake: Gotta check the bathroom again.
Alice: 晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: The mom of the eggs at night...
Jake:鸡蛋
Jake: Eggs.
Shure:  吃鸡蛋的妈是吧
Shure: Is it the mom who eats eggs?
Katrina:  吃鸡
Katrina: Eats eggs.
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, is anyone eating chicken?
Alice: 是和平精英吗
Alice: Is it PUBG?
Alice: 很菜
Alice: I'm not good at it.
Lucia: 其实我也好久没玩那个了
Lucia: Actually, I haven't played it for a long time.
Tasha: 下棋下棋
Tasha: Let's play chess.
Tasha: 打麻将的呢
Tasha: How about Mahjong?
Jake:麻将怎么拿出来呀
Jake: How do we take out the Mahjong set?
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But today I found out...
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: The games in my favorites are 50% off today.
Jake:怎么拿呀
Jake: How do you take it?
Lucia: 先把它拿下来
Lucia: First, take it down.
Alice: Steam吗你玩啥呀
Alice: Steam? What are you playing?
Jake:你会拿吗
Jake: Can you take it?
Tasha: 这个盖子掀起
Tasha: Lift this lid.
Tasha: 来不就行了吗
Tasha: Isn't that fine?
Lucia: 最近在玩使命召唤
Lucia: Recently playing Call of Duty.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:真的吗嗯
Jake: Really? Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯我觉得是
Tasha: Yeah, I think so.
Jake:那不那掀不起来
Jake: But it can't be lifted.
Jake:有没有从旁边拿出来的办法
Jake: Is there a way to take it out from the side?
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe.
Jake:这玩意掀不起来
Jake: This thing can't be lifted.
Shure:  有点有点痴心妄想的我感觉
Shure: It's a bit of wishful thinking, I feel.
Alice: 这边那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Was that mahjong table originally there?
Jake:这边
Jake: Over here.
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously.
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来的
Tasha: It was secretly brought in.
Alice: 私藏进来的
Alice: Secretly brought in.
Shure:  主要他
Shure: Mainly he...
Jake:他原来在这
Jake: He was originally here.
Shure:  哎那就这样吧
Shure: Well, let's leave it at that.
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peony can still soak for a couple more days.
Katrina:  但压花需要两三天啊
Katrina: But pressing flowers takes two or three days.
Lucia: 但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But it hasn't bloomed yet.
Katrina:  没有一朵芍药
Katrina: Not a single peony.
Alice: 那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations.
Alice: 你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming well.
Lucia: 对我康乃馨好旺
Lucia: Yeah, my carnations are thriving.
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peony is so shy.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我看我之前他还没想开
Lucia: I saw it before, it still didn't want to bloom.
Alice: 我的芍药已经开始谢了
Alice: My peony has already started wilting.
Jake:它能催熟吗
Jake: Can it be ripened?
Jake:一天速成
Jake: Speed ripen in one day.
Jake:速开
Jake: Rapid bloom.
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试啊
Lucia: Do you think this is a final exam?
Jake:哈哈哈想让他开他就开
Jake: Hahaha, you think it will bloom just because you want it to?
Alice: 我想开了
Alice: I have come to terms with it.
Lucia: 想开到一半就自闭了
Lucia: I wanted to open it halfway and then got stuck.
Shure:  然后把那个什么弄完
Shure: Then finish that thing.
Shure:  这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: This way, there'll be no worries.
Jake:把那什么拿什么呀
Jake: What do you mean by "that thing"?
Shure:  把我的毕设
Shure: My graduation project.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  我的毕设报告
Shure: My graduation project report.
Shure:  就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: There's just one tiny bit left.
Jake:好那你直播作毕设
Jake:这是压出来了吗
Jake: Is this pressed out?
Katrina:  哈哈哈怎么压的来
Katrina: Hahaha, how did you press it?
Jake:来球球
Jake: Come here, ball.
Katrina:  变干瘪了
Katrina: It's all squished.
Shure:  它压出了不一样的风格
Shure: It pressed out in a different style.
Jake:烟花
Jake: Fireworks.
Katrina:  怎么跟
Katrina: How about
Jake:大烟花有网上的
Jake: Big fireworks on the internet?
Katrina:  跟网上的不太一样
Katrina: It's not quite the same as online.
Jake:网上长啥样
Jake: What does it look like online?
Katrina:  难道是要把它那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Should we peel off the petals one by one?
Katrina:  然后那样子压吗
Katrina: And then press it like that?
Katrina:  然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: If you press the whole flower,
Katrina:  它居然是这个样子
Katrina: It turns out like this.
Jake:这个是什么花
Jake: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina:  我给你看当初的那一张图
Katrina: Let me show you the original picture.
Katrina:  他变成了
Katrina: It turned into
Jake:卖家款
Jake: The seller's version.
Katrina:  特搞笑
Katrina: It's so funny.
Katrina:  当初的图应该是
Katrina: The original picture should be
Katrina:  这样
Katrina: Like this.
Katrina:  哎康乃馨吧
Katrina: Hey, it's a carnation, right?
Jake:花瓣大为啥
Jake: Why are the petals so big?
Katrina:  对就是直接这样子压的话
Katrina: Yeah, if you press it directly like this,
Katrina:  你看他会变成这样
Katrina: Look, it turns out like this.
Katrina:  要么就把它拆开
Katrina: Or you can take it apart.
Katrina:  嗯就是把花瓣一个个剥开
Katrina: Yeah, just peel off the petals one by one.
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: Let me check if there are any guides.
Katrina:  搜一下压花攻略
Katrina: Search for flower pressing guides.
Jake:可以研究研究
Jake: We can research it.
Jake:你看啥呢
Jake: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Tasha: 没事了随便看看
Tasha: It's okay, just looking around.
Jake:搞笑搞笑嗯
Jake: Funny, funny, yeah.
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring.
Jake:压压花哎呀
Tasha: 下棋吗
Tasha: Want to play chess?
Tasha: 找不到事干
Tasha: Can't find anything to do.
Shure:  老板他要摸鱼
Shure: Boss, he wants to slack off.
Jake:收拾收拾跳跳舞
Jake: Clean up, clean up, dance a bit.
Jake:今天也没啥事
Jake: Nothing much to do today.
Jake:收拾收拾房间
Jake: Clean up the room.
Jake:拆拆快递
Jake: Open some packages.
Jake:快递还没到
Jake: The packages haven't arrived yet.
Lucia: 开始装修房子
Lucia: Start renovating the house.
Jake:对快递还没到
Jake: Right, the packages haven't arrived yet.
Tasha: 工具还没到呢没办法装修
Tasha: The tools haven't arrived, can't renovate.
Jake:快递还没到
Jake: The packages haven't arrived yet.
Lucia: 到了一个
Lucia: One has arrived.
Jake:那就等那我问问快递什么时候到
Jake: Then let's wait. I'll ask when the rest will arrive.
Jake:或者再开个小车过去
Jake: Or we could drive over there.
Lucia: 对我今天应该还会有一个快递可以到
Lucia: Right, I should have one more package arriving today.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 京东还是快
Lucia: JD is still fast.
Lucia: 淘宝上那些
Lucia: Those from Taobao...
Lucia: 我就希望他明天能到
Lucia: I just hope it arrives tomorrow.
Jake:嗯那那个
Jake: Hmm, well then...
Jake:那要不集体玩狗去也行
Jake: How about we all play with the dogs?
Shure:  集体玩狗
Shure: All play with the dogs?
Shure:  玩狗 6个人一起撸狗是吧
Shure: Play with the dogs? Six of us petting dogs together?
Jake:对 6个人撸狗去
Jake: Yes, six of us petting dogs.
Lucia: 狗都薅秃了
Lucia: The dogs will be bald.
Jake:狗在哪啊
Jake: Where are the dogs?
Jake:走几步啊
Jake: How far do we have to walk?
Jake:要走多久啊
Jake: How long will it take?
Shure:  200米吧
Shure: About 200 meters.
Jake:那可以去玩狗
Jake: Then we can play with the dogs.
Jake:去就
Jake: Let's go then.
Shure:  狗就说你们才是真的狗
Shure: The dogs will say you guys are the real dogs.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我可能不是人
Lucia: Hahaha, I might not be human.
Lucia: 但你们是真的狗
Lucia: But you guys are the real dogs.
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: Go ahead, say it.
Jake:我觉得
Jake: I think...
Shure:  这句话怎么给南阳理工同学翻译呢
Shure: How do we translate this sentence for the students at Nanyang Technological University?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 没事新加坡中文普及率应该很高
Lucia: No worries, Chinese is quite common in Singapore.
Lucia: 官方语言之一
Lucia: It's one of the official languages.
Shure:  班dog dog哈哈哈
Shure: Class dog dog, hahaha
Jake:Doggy Doggy Doggy
Jake: Doggy, Doggy, Doggy
Jake:就是他们也有那种表情包嘛
Jake: They have those kinds of memes too.
Jake:Doggy Duge是吗
Jake: Doggy Duge, right?
Lucia: 嗯哇这是好多年前的表情包了
Lucia: Yeah, that's a meme from many years ago.
Shure:  咱们这个就这么放着
Shure: Let's just leave it like this.
Shure:  谁干的耶
Shure: Who did it?
Lucia: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Lucia: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Shure:  谁干的
Shure: Who did it?
Jake:来我们一人洗一个
Jake: Come on, let's each wash one.
Lucia: 啊谢谢你
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Jake:好一人洗一个
Shure:  我的我的衣服好了
Shure: My clothes are done.
Lucia: 你啥意思
Lucia: What do you mean?
Jake:你的衣服做好了
Jake: Your clothes are ready.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Shure:  我今天早上那个外面的谁的衣服掉了
Shure: This morning, whose clothes fell outside?
Lucia: 这要不要泡一会再洗之类的
Lucia: Should we soak this for a while before washing?
Lucia: 但这里面有有油
Lucia: There's oil on it.
Lucia: 给他泡到
Lucia: Soak it.
Jake:呃泡着吧
Jake: Uh, let it soak.
Lucia: 泡到这碗
Lucia: Soak this bowl.
Lucia: 这碗还是没
Lucia: This bowl still...
Lucia: 没啥给他接点水
Lucia: Never mind, fill it with some water.
Lucia: 然后等过一会再洗
Lucia: Then wait a bit before washing.
Lucia: 要不然太难搓了
Lucia: Otherwise, it's too hard to scrub.
Jake:好好嘞
Jake: Alright, got it.
Lucia: 啊这还打王者吗
Lucia: Ah, are we still playing King of Glory?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 抱歉
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施了
Lucia: I didn't carry out my evil plan last night.
Lucia: 后来忘记了
Lucia: I ended up forgetting.
Jake:那可以吃
Jake: Then we can eat.
Lucia: 哈哈大反派忘记了他的邪恶计划哈哈
Lucia: Haha, the villain forgot his evil plan, haha!
Jake:变成了一个好人
Jake: He turned into a good person.
Jake:为社会做起的贡献
Jake: Contributing to society.
Lucia: 这什么神偷奶爸剧情
Lucia: What kind of Despicable Me plot is this?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊不
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 他其实最后没有变成好人
Lucia: He actually didn't turn into a good person.
Jake:只是那只是莫名其妙的做了一些贡
Jake: He just did some random good deeds.
Lucia: 对莫名其妙的做了一些好事
Lucia: Yeah, did some random good deeds.
Jake:贡献
Jake: Contributions.
Lucia: 这狗好像河马
Lucia: This dog looks like a hippo.
Lucia: 但它有可能不是狗
Lucia: But it might not be a dog.
Jake:这河马腰挺细
Jake: This hippo has a thin waist.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是为了要方便坐吗
Lucia: Haha, isn't that to make it easier to sit on?
Lucia: 毕竟还是凳子
Lucia: After all, it's still a stool.
Jake:河马不是这这样
Jake: Hippos aren't like that.
Jake:是可以骑
Jake: You can ride them.
Lucia: AI学习一下
Lucia: AI, learn something.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 就人类在房子里面
Lucia: Humans in the house.
Lucia: 就会干一些奇奇怪怪的事情
Lucia: They do weird things.
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 让我想想我们的
Lucia: Let me think, our...
Lucia: 我们现在的瓶子不会就剩这俩了吧
Lucia: We don't just have these two bottles left, right?
Lucia: 这个是方的
Lucia: This one is square.
Lucia: 不太好用
Lucia: Not very useful.
Lucia: 只有那个稍微好用点
Lucia: Only that one is a bit useful.
Jake:我们那个金币是谁买的呀
Jake: Who bought our gold coins?
Jake:就是拍卖用的金币哦
Jake: The coins for the auction, oh.
Jake:爆金币爆什么
Jake: What's the deal with the gold coins?
Lucia: 哎我记得那天是谁说用贴对
Lucia: Hey, I remember someone said to use stickers.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 贴画就可以来着
Lucia: Stickers would work.
Lucia: 对所以应该是本来就有吧
Lucia: So we should already have them, right?
Lucia: 好像是雨轩
Lucia: I think it was Yuxuan.
Lucia: 问问雨轩好
Lucia: Let's ask Yuxuan.
Shure:  行不行咱们踩点纸壳子就行
Shure: How about we just step on some cardboard?
Lucia: 可以有人要做狗吗
Lucia: Can anyone be a dog?
Lucia: 不是有人
Lucia: Not anyone.
Jake:可以我们都可以
Jake: Sure, we all can.
Jake:我们都很狗
Jake: We're all like dogs.
Lucia: 有人做狗吗
Lucia: Is someone acting like a dog?
Jake:哈哈我们承认我们很
Jake: Haha, we admit we're very...
Shure:  狗弄完之后
Shure: After playing with the dog...
Jake:我们可以做狗
Jake: We can act like dogs.
Lucia: 就这个狗吧
Lucia: Just this dog, right?
Lucia: 他可以他就是他
Lucia: He can, he really can.
Lucia: 可以做的好一些
Lucia: He can do it better.
Lucia: 可以做的那个潦草一些
Lucia: Or do it a bit more sloppy.
Jake:那做狗吧
Jake: Then let's be dogs.
Jake:今天我们一起做
Jake: Today we'll be together.
Lucia: 今天我们一起做狗
Lucia: Today, we'll be dogs together.
Lucia: 不是跟狗杠上了是吧
Lucia: Aren't we just arguing with the dog?
Lucia: 一会要撸狗是吧
Lucia: Are we going to pet the dog later?
Jake:对先先玩狗
Jake: Yeah, let's play with the dog first.
Shure:  我们给他做一套铠甲
Shure: Let's make him a suit of armor.
Jake:再哈哈哈哈
Jake: Then haha...
Lucia: 哈哈哈那这就交给您了
Lucia: Haha, then I'll leave it to you.
Lucia: 我这个难度有点高
Lucia: This is a bit challenging for me.
Lucia: 对我觉得我们这纸箱还是挺多的
Lucia: Yeah, I think we have quite a lot of cardboard boxes.
Lucia: 需要有
Lucia: We need...
Shure:  我们中午吃什么呢
Shure: What are we having for lunch?
Lucia: 尺子
Lucia: A ruler.
Jake:中午还能吃什么呢
Jake: What else can we eat for lunch?
Jake:我们有别的选项吗
Jake: Do we have other options?
Shure:  外卖是吗
Shure: Delivery, right?
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: Sounds good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  我们可以把或者或者或者鸡蛋全给炒
Shure: We can fry all the eggs or...
Jake:或者或者是
Jake: Or, or...
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha...
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe...
Jake:今天摄氮量过多不太好
Jake: Eating too much nitrogen is not good.
Shure:  弄个柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Let's make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure:  再加个苜蓿是
Shure: And add some alfalfa.
Jake:呵呵呵你听到了吧
Jake: Hehe, did you hear that?
Jake:鲁西
Jake: Lucia.
Lucia: 不是啊什么呀
Lucia: No, what?
Jake:什么呀啊
Jake: What? Ah.
Lucia: 啊刚刚他说什么
Lucia: Ah, what did he just say?
Jake:先做一个西红柿炒鸡蛋
Jake: First, make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Jake:再做个木须肉
Jake: Then, make Moo Shu Pork.
Jake:哈哈哇
Jake: Haha, wow.
Lucia: 哇别吧
Lucia: Wow, no way.
Lucia: 从我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Everywhere I go, I'll treat everyone to a big plate of scrambled eggs.
Jake:我觉得可以啊
Jake: I think that's fine.
Jake:最后一天我们就这么做吧
Jake: Let's do that on the last day.
Lucia: 啊那我只负责炒西红柿炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Ah, then I'll only be responsible for scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Lucia: 木须肉我不会做
Lucia: I don't know how to make Moo Shu Pork.
Jake:好好那行那我
Jake: Alright, alright, then I'll...
Jake:那你会做木须肉吗
Jake: Do you know how to make Moo Shu Pork?
Jake:嗯那哎
Jake: Hmm, well, um...
Jake:坐坐坐就能坐着
Jake: Just sit, sit, sit.
Jake:整点黄瓜
Jake: Let's get some cucumbers.
Jake:买点黄瓜去
Jake: Go buy some cucumbers.
Lucia: 到时候给大家吃了
Lucia: We'll serve them to everyone.
Lucia: 一个月都不想看见鸡蛋哈哈
Lucia: I won't want to see eggs for a whole month, haha.
Jake:点个我
Jake: Order me.
Jake:要不就点外卖
Jake: Or just order delivery.
Jake:西红柿炒蛋和木须肉
Jake: Scrambled eggs with tomatoes and Moo Shu Pork.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:咱不做了
Jake: Let's not cook anymore.
Jake:哈哈你不是做毕设吗
Shure:  对我要做毕设
Shure: Yeah, I need to do my graduation project.
Jake:哈哈你自己设的
Jake: Haha, you designed it yourself.
Lucia: 哎呀让我拿过来
Lucia: Oh, let me take it over.
Jake:挺美观的
Jake: It looks pretty good.
Shure:  毕设哎
Shure: Graduation project, sigh.
Shure:  我要把我偷来的代码改成自己的
Shure: I need to change the code I stole to make it look like my own.
Jake:呵呵呵可以
Jake: Haha, sure.
Shure:  这个杨老板应该很擅长吧
Shure: Jake, you must be pretty good at this, right?
Jake:这个现在已经不偷代码了
Jake: Now I don't steal code anymore.
Shure:  现在都告原创了
Shure: Now it's all about originality.
Jake:GPT直接写了还
Jake: GPT writes it directly now.
Jake:呃等快递啊可能是
Jake: Uh, waiting for a delivery, maybe.
Alice: 他们去哪了
Alice: Where did they go?